good evening
you know how i love working with legends
oh my baby
and i'm honored to present the final
award of the evening with a true
show business legend
she's celebrating the 50th anniversary
of cabaret
oscar award-winning actress
liza minnelli
[Applause]
throughout the night
we've seen highlights
of the 10
best
nominee
you know nominated for best picture
awards
now we're going to show you something
else
and then
we're going to tell you what these are
right now oh good
i
[Music]
[Applause]
don't look up
[Applause]
drive my car
[Applause]
dune
[Music]
king richard
licorice pizza
nightmare
alley the power of the dog
[Applause]
west side story
[Music]
[Applause]
all right liza yes
hi everybody
i'm so happy to be here and especially
with you i'm your biggest fan are you
excited to announce best picture and the
oscar goes to
okay coda
[Applause]
coda has three academy award nominations
this year winning all three
for actor in a supporting role adapted
screenplay and best picture
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank
oh wow
oh wow
thank thank you to the academy for
letting our coda make history tonight
um
and
congratulations to all of our fellow
nominees your movies were all so
incredible we're so honored to be here
sean
it hasn't been an easy ride from our
first day shooting
when our cast and crew was were supposed
to be at 4 am at sea fishing when we
were told the giant storm was about to
hit us
it was only the beginning of our
problems
but you've been
you've kept the boat afloat and your
best you've been the best captain a
producer can ever dreamed of
really
to
our incredible cast
you guys have made and
such a wonderful and loving family on
screen but also off screen
and everybody want to be a part of it
and contrary to you ruby no one wants to
seem no one seems to want to leave it
so you guys
and
i want to thank eric our partner in
paris and our team at vanduum i want to
thank my better half
leah and my kids who are all here i love
you
i want to thank terry samuel for
mentoring me at my early days and lastly
i want to thank my dad
i hope you're watching
from a bear
i love you very much and this one's for
you too
[Music]
well
i really
i really want to thank the academy for
recognizing
a movie of
love and family on this difficult time
that we need today and this is koda
uh sean
you've been absolutely where are you
you've been absolutely amazing from the
first day i'm so blessed that i've met
you
and uh to our cast
academy award winner
molly matalin new academy award winner
troy cutzer
danielle duran
emilia your voice charmed us
and you organized you made us laugh so
much
and
you really took really great care of the
ruby family i want to thank also
the incredible crew that we had
in
including the fishermen community in
gloucester
the
the incredible
team at apple tv they've been absolutely
amazing
from from day one and and really
were able to basically
put this movie
everywhere in the world really thank you
all of you
all of you and the most amazing team
um
and to my father who is not there and my
motto is not there but my beautiful
daughter olivia she's here the other one
justine is not here and my wonderful
wife who have been supporting me i don't
know how they made it for so long
thank you thank you thank you